for more than 50 years colleges have
taken different approaches towards
admissions to make their campuses more
diverse
considering an applicant's race
generally called affirmative action has
long been standard at universities from
UPenn to Harvard but not anymore the
Supreme Court has ruled that no College
in the U.S can consider an applicant's
race in admissions
nine states have already banned this
practice California did almost 25 years
ago just enough time for a detailed
study on its consequences once you have
the data set in hand there's an awful
lot you can learn honestly pretty
quickly right basically what I'm doing
is just differences and means what
happened to the kids after 98 what
happened to the kids before 98 just
those comparisons tell you an awful lot
about not just what happened in
California but I think what we can
expect to happen across the country
here's how affirmative action changed
College admissions and what the future
of higher EDU Mission might look like
without it
foreign
which of these student applicants would
be accepted was fairly simple most
colleges would essentially filter
students they'd set factors like a
minimum GPA or a minimum test score and
voila there's your pool of accepted
students obviously the more selective
the school the higher those standards
were but a big part of both test scores
and grades are pre-18 educational
investment and honestly non-educational
investment the degree to which you had a
stable household the degree to which you
had a some notion of you know being able
to focus on your work the better a high
school you go to the better the test
score you get the better uh you know
sort of access to resources outside of
high school like tutoring or other
services that you had access to before
18 the better you test
you break down sh at scores by the
background of the student
s from higher income households score
higher same if you look at who grew up
in a household with a parent with a
graduate degree versus no degree that
also reflects in race with Black and
Hispanic students scoring lower than
white and Asian students
so in the 1970s when UC Berkeley's
admissions really just looked at GPA and
test scores the student population was
less than five percent Black and
Hispanic students who might have been
really high ability just weren't able to
get the kind of education that would
lead them to the kind of high
standardized tests that would get them
into a school like Berkeley these
schools recognized that they needed some
way of admitting those students and so
they started affirmative action policies
to try to bring in students from sort of
every part of in this case the state of
California so in the 80s they began
considering race in their admissions
decisions it worked
by the 90s they would chart students on
a social diversity index
if you were low income and a minority
and had moderate grades and test scores
you were in
if you were high income and white you
needed higher scores to get in
some colleges like the UC Davis school
of medicine used quotas utilizing a
similar filtering system but a few spots
would be reserved for minority
applicants in the late 70s a white
student named Becky fell here not good
enough to get in among other white
applicants but with higher test scores
and GPA than the minority students who
got in he sued claiming discrimination
it made it to the Supreme Court he won
and was admitted
the Court ruled that while the goal of
achieving a diverse student body is
sufficiently compelling to justify
consideration of race and admissions
decisions specific quotas went too far
more than two dozen Supreme Court cases
have followed including the landmark
grudder V Bollinger in 2003 which upheld
that race could be considered as part of
a highly individualized holistic review
of each applicant's file that's
essentially how affirmative action has
worked the last 20 years instead of just
filtering a pool of applicants most
colleges look at each person
individually like Harvard we'll look at
sat and GPA but also things like
extracurricular activities essays Awards
life experiences recommendations
leadership and yes race
but this is exactly what the Supreme
Court has now struck down
in two separate cases against Harvard
and the University of North Carolina
plaintiffs argued this holistic approach
was just a cover for discrimination
against white and Asian students the
Supreme Court agreed ruling that
eliminating racial discrimination means
eliminating all of it the student must
be treated based on his or her
experiences as an individual not on the
basis of race many universities have for
too long done just the opposite which
means in this holistic review race can
no longer be considered to the degree
that these universities want to maintain
their current level of racial diversity
California has shown that that is
infeasible at least given the policies
that California has tried to implement
in the 90s Californians voted for
proposition 209 which banned public
universities from considering race Zach
bloemer conducted a massive study in
California following students that
applied before and after prop 209
looking at where they eventually
enrolled graduated and then at their
wage statements so you can see so long
as they stay in the state of California
where they work and how much they earn
all the way through 2020 you know 25
years almost after the affirmative
action ban was implemented what he found
was that Black and Hispanic enrollments
at more selective schools like Berkeley
dramatically fell when they couldn't
include race in their admissions process
moderately selective schools had almost
no change but enrollment at less
selective schools actually Rose because
most Black and Hispanic students didn't
not go to college they just went to less
esteemed ones you got this Cascade
effect of Black and Hispanic students on
average enrolling at a university that's
just a little bit less selective than
the universities they used to have
access to kids who used to go to
Berkeley are now going to UC Davis kids
who used to go to UC Davis are now going
to UC Santa Cruz what happened is pretty
substantial negative ramifications for
these students
they became less likely to earn stem
degrees
less likely to go to graduate school
those with the lowest GPA and test
scores became less likely to even
graduate
and overall Black and Hispanic students
earned Less in their careers than those
admitted before prop 209 one thing we've
learned from affirmative action bands is
that the kids who are admitted to more
selective universities as a result of
race-based affirmative action tend to
receive greater value from those
institutions in terms of the degree to
which those institutions lead them to
more successful jobs or more success
generally in the labor market than the
wider Asian students who tend to take
their places after the end of
affirmative action programs bloemer has
also studied the effects of what's
called race neutral admissions policies
which can include Outreach and
income-based admissions as has
Georgetown University they both found
the same result it seems like all of
these race neutral Alternatives that
universities can Implement have a
tendency toward increasing the diversity
of campuses but they don't give you
anywhere close to the level of racial
diversity that's provided by race-based
affirmative action Harvard said if it
were to not include race in their
holistic review Black and Hispanic
enrollment will decline by almost half
Berkeley even though it has made stride
since prop 209 to enroll more Hispanic
students the black student population is
still below where it was when it could
consider race and admissions I think
we'll see declines in Black and Hispanic
enrollment potentially in some cases
quite severe declines in the next couple
of years and as a result you're going to
have this sort of downward shift black
Hispanic students enrolling at less
selective schools than they had access
to previously there's no clear Silver
Bullet for such universities just to
maintain diversity as it is right now
foreign
[Music]